foreign
let's go out to Richmond Virginia and
talk to Olivia what's up Olivia
yes hello yes hello to you what's up
I'm nothing thanks for taking my call
are you nervous I can hear it in you
I am okay don't be nervous it's all good
man it's all good all right well um I
wrote in because I found out recently
that someone I went to high school with
um got employed by the high school and
like a counselor job and
um I it was just deeply bothered by it I
feel like there's a lot that people
there don't know about
them and
um I want my kids to go there and I just
I kind of want to you know talk to the
people that I
um am close with at the school about it
but I'm like not really wanting to open
that can of worms so just wanted to know
what I should do how I should deal with
it
so you're pretty Coy with a they
is this a mean girl situation or is this
a guy that hurt you
no it's a girl
um and yeah like we we played Sports
together we
um she's just not a good person what
does that mean um just lying cheating
um just like knows how to fool the
adults when we were in high school and
um
damn
26.
let me just say
I
think God I'm not judged right now on
who I was at 16 and 17 and 18.
like I get that I really do and like I
talk to my parents about this too and
they were like you know people change
but like
I
have mutual friends with this person and
it's just not like I'm sorry but it's
just not and
this is not they're like I I'm sorry
that I am still holding her accountable
for these things but she hasn't changed
and give me some examples of how she
hasn't changed how she's still lying and
cheating and swindling people as an
adult
yeah so like she
um
let me just try to like gather what I
want to say
so she like is very up much into like
the hookup culture and this is a this is
like a religious High School okay she's
um like she gets drunk she uses drugs
not I mean she smokes weed occasionally
um and like just not her morals and the
values of her life don't align to what
this school is about and that's why I
feel like every close adult which is
basically my parents I've told they were
like what like I'm sorry who who let
that happen you know and so I'm just
thinking which I know this is not
realistic but like and
15 years if my kids go there how am I
going to deal with that like yeah
uh let's let 15 years the world's gonna
be very different in 15 years I'm afraid
so not afraid I'm excited about it
um yeah how do you know
how do you know she does drugs and
drinks and because I know the people she
doesn't with okay so let's do a couple
of things number one
let's let High School go
just let it go and that's why I'm
calling I'm like I don't care about this
like I have but a whole life you do it's
in it's in your it's exactly I didn't
think I did I didn't think I did
and then this this brought it all back
up and I'm just like and enraged over it
okay
you're the the enrage part like so let's
take her out of the picture if you heard
that some local faith-based high school
hired somebody that's hooking up and
drinking beers
um
you probably roll your eyes
or are you a small town like can you
believe can you whatever
the rage comes from what happened in
high school
and we can get into that like you are
killing yourself by not letting that go
you've probably heard the old phrase you
are drinking poison hoping that she dies
yeah your boy you know what she hasn't
thought about in a long time you
or any of this stuff that happened
but you do
and it causes your heart to go up it
causes your all sorts of physiological
issues here
your heart rate to go up
it's killing you
Let It Go yeah don't hold it back
anymore as the great Frozen says
that's why I'm like I don't know how
though
so
a couple of things number one and we'll
get to the actual issue as an adult
number one
um as a practice I started about a
decade ago um I don't have to do it
hardly at all anymore occasionally but
hardly at all
um
but I literally made a commitment to
myself that I would stop having
imaginary conversations in my head with
other people who are not in the room
yeah
and you you're amazing at it I can tell
and you always win them too don't you
like you drop bombs when you're you have
these fantasies of when you talk to her
and you're gonna Point your finger at
her can you do this and she's gonna be
like oh my gosh you're right I did and
it's gonna feel so awesome
your body doesn't know the difference
and so you spin your body up for war all
the time
and you're never gonna have those
conversations you'll never have that
confrontation and if you do it will not
go anything like you think it's going to
yeah and so I literally would walk
through my house and I would yell out
loud nope
I've heard of people with rubber bands
and they pop them on their wrist I've
heard of people who will like Snap their
fingers anything that will break you out
of that cycle because it's instantaneous
your body wants that hit it's addicted
to that cycle that stress cycle get out
of it
and what you have to do is you have to
catch yourself and it will take a while
but stop with the imaginary
conversations and when high school stuff
comes up just stop
number two you probably need to go talk
to a counselor because there's probably
some stuff that happened in high school
is that fair
yeah some ugly stuff Fair
is there stuff you haven't told people
about
green though it's not that dark it's
just
I don't know it just felt so undeserving
you know let me ask you this what do you
do for a living
I'm self-employed
I'm pulling our life it's not about that
it's just I'm just asking you what do
you like what do you do
we own our own business okay y'all doing
great you love it
yeah
okay
can you let her just love her thing too
yeah and it's not so much about
like not wanting happiness I'm not that
bitter it's just that
I just don't think he should be in the
position you know okay that leads me
number two age number two if you know of
somebody who is who is openly violating
the core tenants of a place where they
work
then you have to make a grown-up
decision as to whether I'm going to
report that I'm going to say something
to them I'm gonna bring it up or what
but I want to challenge you to make your
decision and either say something or
make your decision to not say anything
and move on with your life because
you're caught in this gray area and
you're torturing yourself
yeah I agree three and that's kind of
what I'm saying like is just moving on
fine because like morally I just feel
like
I don't think they asked you yeah you're
right I mean the school didn't like put
out feelers and be like like whenever I
got my job at Belmont they had an open
call right they put it in the paper
here's the finalists they had a um open
like a forum where anybody could come in
right it was open like you got something
to say say it now it's like forever hold
your peace right
yeah physical didn't ask you for that
yeah you're right so you're you want to
insert yourself into a situation does it
yeah and that's what I'm saying I don't
feel like it's my place but I just want
to like not be so bothered by it
I think you want to burn her to the
ground
I I mean it's really not I don't feel
like it's that bad I just I promise you
I really it is
it it is
and I I can't tell you I would let it go
yeah and if there's something going
wrong that's wrong right like and I I
could see myself having a conversation
with an executive somewhere I would have
no problem with that if I felt like my
values and morals were challenged on a
particular situation
letting somebody know hey I need you to
know this about this person I've done
that recently actually
it was a super egregious situation but I
was pretty clear
yeah right and so if you feel like you
need to do that do it just do it
but if you're not gonna do that walk
away
yeah walk away and I want to catch
myself here I said they didn't invite
you into this conversation like you're
inserting yourself in the problem
sometimes good citizens do
they run into the middle of a situation
because they see something that somebody
else doesn't see
I don't want someone a house on fire and
sitting out in the front yard and be
like well they never asked me to come
help them so I'm just going to watch it
burn down don't do that right yeah yeah
so if you know somebody is doing some
unethical or illegal or they're they are
pulling the wool over especially as a
teacher right and as an educator as a
mental health professional as a
counselor for God's sake yeah maybe you
do say something
maybe you go to that person first and
you say hey
this isn't cool
um and you get involved that way that's
cool that's fine
but make your decision and then be done
with it and I want you to practice over
the next 30 60 days I want you to
practice when you start that imaginary
conversation when she's in your head
literally say out loud stop no not doing
this I'm being present where I am
what happened in high school happened in
high school
it was a long it was eight years ago
almost a decade ago let it ride and if
there are some hard things you need to
talk about some things that weren't fair
some things that hurt you
grief demands a witness you need to say
those things out loud in front of
somebody who will hear you
okay
so call a local counselor
book a couple of sessions
but there's some sort of thing in you
that you had to overcome a lot and
you've got a successful business
and she lied and cheated and stole her
way
she's still doing it and now she's got
this successful job like helping young
people no
she doesn't get to do that
and I would just say man let the
self-righteousness Go Let It Go
let High School be high school thank God
I'm not judged on who I was in high
school
hopefully I've grown up a lot
hopefully I've gone up a lot
and maybe just maybe
if somebody calls her out an appropriate
way she'll go you're right I'm sorry
or maybe she just needs to be removed
from that position
thank you
or maybe
you can work real hard
to set that brick down and just let her
out of your life for good